it's 9pm on New Year's Eve
two hours before curfew starts many are
heading home
but others are just getting started hi
hi thank you Eugene worked in media and
advertising before the Russian invasion
he's now enlisted in the Army and
entering the new year with old friends
but a new life so what's going on with
the curfew you guys aren't going to go
anywhere
no of course not we abide the law we
abide the law we buy the law but at six
in the morning when curfew ends that's
when the club's open
for young Ukrainian celebration is in
itself resistance why is it important
for ukrainians to come together and
celebrate New Year's oh just because the
main idea of what's doing in Russia
right now is to like terrorize us and to
put out ourselves in fear and that's
they're not getting this so we will um
just live our lives and also it might be
inconvenient but it doesn't matter so
Russia invades Ukraine in February
and you both decide to join the military
service uh yes for uh for me it was uh
just unimaginable to stay aside because
uh I went to Army not to protect country
or my government or even language I came
I joined the forces to protect my family
my way of living the freedom we have
here in Ukraine
[Music]
it's just after midnight but instead of
fireworks
yeah
with ukrainians taking to balconies to
defiantly sing their national anthem
[Applause]
and a message from the president
the curfew ends and a new day begins
we're being kept at home overnight
people are here celebrating New Year's
Day by looking at what our remnants of a
year of War but the hope is is that 2023
will bring an end to the conflict
for families looking ahead the Year is
off to an ominous start
I wanted to believe that we would have
like calm night at least but no
our neighbors decided that we do not
deserve it so they send us a new year
presents and it was disgusting really we
all had plans one year ago to travel to
some places to do some things to get a
new job for me personally and with the
start of the war all the plans went to
the trash bin yeah
last year Ukraine's fighting Spirit
captured the world's imagination but for
2023 their hope is that there won't be a
need to fight at all
Sky News Kiev